the most and there's nothing wrong with
this by the way i'm not i have no
problem with these people it is their
right and i understand the value in it
but i think that we only have kind of
two groups of people people who go out
with the intimidating plate carriers the
ar-15s or the ak-47s and their ski
goggles and they say it's my right and
it is their right and then you have
people who are really afraid of it and
so i said i want to go and do an open
carry but i want to do an open carry
walk the way i would want most people to
open carry and that would be you know
something on your hip so some of us had
hip holsters and i said you know i'll
put on a shoulder holster because for
some reason i don't know why uh you add
some leather and steel and it's less
intimidating to people than like a black
polymer gun because people don't know
they assume black polymer is scary it's
a 50 cal so it started with that and
then i realized it was just really
comfortable and when i came home i mean
my wife just what she would i mean she
was adapts she was a demon